Stanley is one of the most recognizable
figures in pop culture not only did he
co-create many of the world's most
popular superheroes he frequently
appears alongside them in movies TV
shows and comic books here are some of
our favorite times that Stan was the man
Stan the supervillain Stan and
collaborator Jack Kirby have been super
involved with their creation since the
1950s and they used to cosplay for their
own comic book covers they outdid
themselves the Fantastic Four number 10
which stars the pair being forced to
assist Doctor Doom in a scheme to defeat
Reed Richards
luckily Reed saves the day in the end
Stan the superhero in 1978 Stan went
from fighting the Fantastic Four to
becoming team leader what if number 11
explores what might have happened if
Stan and the rest of the original Marvel
creative team Jack Kirby Sol Brodsky and
Flo Steinberg had become the Fantastic
Four
spoiler alert not only did they defeat
the evil aliens they do it while putting
out comics about their own adventures
leave it to stand to save the world in a
spare time Stan the superhero part - one
of the coolest Stan Lee cameos came in
Disney's big hero six based loosely on a
Marvel comic that Stan didn't have
anything to do with the film pay tribute
to Marvel's living mascot with a post
credit scene revealing he's actually the
father of superhero wannabe Fred even
better stan is secretly a superhero
himself
Stan the librarian may be the funniest
of olive lee's many movie cameos was in
the amazing spider-man Spidey in the
lizard trash an entire library but
neither of them can lay a finger on Stan
was oblivious to their tussle thanks to
his sick beats by dre stand the wedding
crasher considering Stan Lee co-created
the Fantastic Four you'd think he'd get
an invite to Reed and Sue's wedding but
Stan actually had to crash the wedding
not once but twice first in the comics
accompanied by Jack Kirby and then in
the movies in Fantastic Four rides the
Silver Surfer he was shown the door both
times
imitation sir and I should be on that
list name Stanley yeah nice try buddy
Stan the Guru threw out Kevin Smith's
1995 cult classic Mallrats Jason Lee's
character Brodie talks about Stanley's
awesomeness just like we're doing now at
a key moment Stan suddenly shows up and
delivers a rousing inspirational speech
that turns Brody around allowing him to
save the day if only were that easy to
summon Stan when you needed him we'll
just have to settle for his doll instead
Stan the man
given that he's pushing a hundred Stan
is like everyone's grandpa that's why I
was so surprising to see him show up in
a strip club in Deadpool
in real life Stan is anything but a
player he and his wife Joan have been
married for seven decades but Stan strip
club appearance is just one of several
cameos showing stands surrounded by
ladies an Iron Man Tony Stark
accidentally confused a Stanford playboy
creator Hugh Hefner while in guardians
of the galaxy we see Stan working his
mojo Guardians director James Gunn
originally had a different idea for
Stan's cameo though he wanted stand to
be shown in one of the collectors cages
only to have his head blown off when the
collectors museum is leveled by an
explosion now that's going out thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which Stan Lee moment you
thought was his most epic